this is pretty horrifying here's
representative katie porter talking to
uh greater greta thuneberg
and i'm not sure why she's talking to
greta philbert but she is and she
reveals how
she porter is emotionally and
psychologically abusing her own daughter
let's listen to this
i told my nine-year-old daughter that i
was going to be speaking with you and i
said what do you think about
the climate change climate change and
she said the earth is on fire
and we're all going to die soon and i
asked her how that made her feel
and she said it made her feel angry
what should i tell my daughter and how
should i help her
and the youngest generation bear the
emotional
toll of the actions that we're
taking fossil fuel companies are taking
to destroy our planet
well it's thank you for a question um
that's a big big question and i know
that there are many young people
who feel angry and sad because of all
the things
that some people are are doing okay shut
up credit let me uh let me answer that
can i jump in here
let me actually answer that question for
representative porter
what do you tell your daughter when she
says she's afraid because the earth is
on fire and everyone's going to die
well you lunatic you tell her
that that's not true and she's gonna be
okay
that's what you tell a child when
they're afraid
especially when they're afraid of
something that legitimately isn't true
so there's nothing to think about it
it's it's it would be like if i went
into my daughter's room
at night because she's crying and uh i
say what's wrong and she tells me daddy
there's monsters under the bed
what if i were to respond are there's
monsters under your bed how does that
make you feel
it makes me feel really scared yeah it
is scary
well anyway i'm gonna hit the sack see
you later good luck with the monsters
no what you tell your daughter is no
there's no monsters
i'll go look i'll go check i'll fight
the monsters if there's any oh no
there's no monsters you're okay
everything will be fine daddy's here
you'll be okay
i mean the fear that the earth is on
fire and that we're all going to die of
climate change
is as ludicrous as the fear that there
are monsters under the bed
but you can't blame a child for having
ludicrous fears they're they're children
and if you've told them this then what
else are they supposed to think i mean
unfortunately katie porter's parents
are rather children have katie porter as
a parent
and sadly they're going to believe
whatever katie porter tells them
it's not until they're older and they're
out of the house where they can start to
realize that their mother was a
abusive lunatic psychologically
manipulating them
the earth is on come on you know what
i have a lot of fears for for my own
children
which i talk about all the time i i
worry very much about the world
that they're going to live in i worry
about the culture they're going to live
in i worry about the country that we're
leaving for them i worry about all of
those things
but i am not worried that climate change
is going to kill them
not anywhere on my list of worries
they'll be perfectly fine as far as that
goes
as far as everything else i don't know
but you know what even even my my my
valid
worries and concerns
i'm not telling my kids about that there
are a lot of really real things out
there in the world
to be worried about you know there are a
lot of things out there in the world
that could
harm my kids could kill them god forbid
could
could uh corrupt them could all kinds of
things
could ruin their lives i mean there are
there's a lot a lot of terrible things
that could happen to them
that's the reality i'm not telling them
that
they don't know about almost any of it
because i they don't need to know
right now they're with me
and my wife we're there to protect them
eventually we won't be so over time you
start to introduce them to some of these
realities but
at the age of six seven eight
no need
you could protect them from those
realities and you could you could
protect them from the realities
as a parent and you could especially
protect them from things that are not a
reality
such as the concern that climate change
is going to destroy the earth because
it's not
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content